foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight on Facebook and uncensored the
front runner to be Scotland's next
leader says the future of the monarchy
is now on the table
can the Royals survive the age of
populism and attacks on privilege is the
SMP plotting to Dethrone the king will
debate
as prime minister Rishi sune pledges to
review sex education in schools amid a
growing rub at graphic lessons for kids
how young is too young to learn about
sex
an attacked abused and briefly jail for
a crime he never committed Jordan
trangrove's life was turned inside out
by an evil fantasist tonight his accuser
is behind bars and Jordan joins me live
live from London
is Piers Morgan uncensored good evening
Roberto welcome to Pierce Morgan
uncensored at First Sight the British
Monarchy should already be finished
let's face it many people see privilege
as a crime against equal opportunity the
monarchy meme was undeniably built on
illogical birthrights populism rages
against Elites but they're all found
near the most obvious Elites of them all
tribalism and Brash opinions dominate
public debate in an age of identity
politics but were quietly ruled by an
unspeaking authority that takes
absolutely no position and that's really
the whole point fickle politicians tear
strips of each other and Survive by
dividing us but the monarchy is a
constant reassuring Above The Fray
that's why it's not only survived but
thrives Against All Odds but there is
growing evidence of cracks in Britain's
Gilded Age Hamza Youssef who's the front
runner to be Scotland's next leader has
put the future of the monarchy firmly on
the table
I'm a republican I believe that we
should be Citizens First not subjects so
we keep the monarchy for a period of
time then I'd hope Scotland an
independent Scotland been moved to be a
republic in the future
well since then Mr Youssef has doubled
down on his statement promising to give
the Scottish people a vote on whether to
have a monarch or an elected head of
state within five years and then
independent of Scotland is not the only
threat to the monarchy the late Queen
was emphatically more popular than King
Charles for now anyway and young people
are much less enthusiastic about the
monarchy Harry and Megan's Antics and
that a global Crusade is smears against
an unfashable and what they tried to
call a racist institution Prince
Andrew's squalid Scandal has heaped
massive embarrassment on the winses and
indeed the institution of the monarchy
Australia has scrubbed King Charles from
his banknotes Barbados ditched the lake
queen as head of state Jamaica will be
next to become a Republic and the Royals
are Barrett by protests and demands for
reparations whenever they tour the
Commonwealth force in King Charles to
say this
from The Darkest Days of our past
and the appalling atrocity of slavery
which forever stains our history
the people of this island forged their
path with extraordinary fortitude
well whether the monarchy can survive
the era of constant hammering apologies
the historical sins is suddenly a rather
urgent question but it should the
monarchy keeps our sense of nation and
patriotism separate from politics it
gives us a reason to unite love our
country it's traditions and its identity
it's above the Venom of everyday
political debate we're confused the head
of state with the head of government
like the U.S or turkey or Brazil would
that really bring us closer together
though evidence that it does
God forbid we have a ballot of president
farage
we could have a ceremonial Overlord like
Germany or Ireland who cuts ribbons and
shakes hands with the cameras is that
seriously any better for brown Britain
than the Pomp and pageantry of our
oldest greatest tradition the Royal
sometimes disappoint us they're not
perfect they're humans but the monarchy
is worth defending I guess political
attacks like this one from a Scottish
nationalists and it starts with
celebrating it not constantly
apologizing for its past well joining me
now is the former first minister of
Scotland Alex salmon talked to if he
contributor Paula Roan Adrian and chief
executive of the campaign group Republic
Graham Smith welcome to you all so
Alexander
um
don't know much about him although he's
popped up may replace Nicholas sturgeon
from all the polls yes the book is
favorite yeah uh which is probably never
a place you really want to find yourself
at this stage of the race but he is
clearly not a monarchist and clearly
thinks we should just get rid of the
monarchy do you agree with him I think
he's probably right I mean it was
different when I was first Minister the
queen was head of state you had to be
insane to to suggest replacing Her
Majesty the queen because of her long
service of popularity her wisdom
what different situation now and it's
quite interesting if you ask people in
Scotland do you want to keep the
monarchy or get the Republic you'll
probably get a majority for the monarchy
if you ask the question if you're
setting up an independent Scotland a new
country should just start with an
elected head of state then the answer is
quite different you shouldn't you should
move to uh an elected head of state as
opposed to the hereditary principle so
what do you think what is your intrinsic
argument about the monarchy because the
arguments I hear against it is well they
cost too much money but that's probably
not true well there are net positive
that's not my arguments all right so
let's start I'm sure it might be one of
yours but we'll part them because if
they're a net positive so is it just the
idea of unelected family which is at the
head of the country I think if you're
setting up a new Democratic country you
wouldn't start from the hereditary
principle the monarchy
why not well why not I don't know well
in recent times I mean if you go back a
hundred years new countries started with
new money I mean you know like Norway
imported I don't know a minor German
line from somewhere if I remember
correctly remember a minor Swedish line
but right now in the 21st century you
wouldn't start from the Henry principle
uh also I I tend to I think there's a
presidential test in this piece see if
Britain had become a republic during her
majesty the Queen's reign and she
decided to stand as an elected president
she had a wiped the floor with any
candidate yeah I mean that wouldn't be
the case with King Charles I mean Gary
lineker would be King Charles you
probably would beat King Charles that
sounds so surprising so so therefore
last year as well if I went the other
way 21st century Democratic age you're
setting up a new Society written
Constitution protecting people's rights
the monarchy to an extent at least is
the Pinnacle of a class system
it is it is but when I look at the way
that the American system has worked with
this two-party system fraught with
corruption thought with people you just
have to have a big enough bank balance
to run for president you know the the
division they have in that country I
look at the division in this country I
look at the procession of useless
leaders we've had the one constant we've
had and I genuinely believe this has
been the queen and now Charles we've had
two monarchs in my lifetime and I do
think they provide by the country with
just a comfort blanket which should not
be underestimated why are you laughing
because we don't need a comfort blanket
I mean I think we do actually why I mean
it's so patronizing and we're so
unpadriotic because yes we need a
comfort blanket uh I have never heard a
good argument for the monarchy and it
certainly isn't a net positive you
didn't see any positives about the queen
there's no well I mean it's not about
the Queens it's about the monarchy she
was the head of the monarchy and now we
have for 70 years but now we have it but
you saw that just to be clear you saw no
positives in the queen it's not about
the queen it's about the model I'm
asking you about the queen well I don't
really know her and that's the problem
we don't know none of us none of us
for 48 years of your life
don't squirm off the old net here no
because the issue is the monarchy did
you not understand that she was one of
the not if the most respected people in
the world well I I think that's
disputable but I mean the point is who
is more respected than her that's a
silly answer give me a name this is a
deadline this is a dead end I'm not sure
if you're familiar
do you not see any positives in the
queen you'd say no
the argument is about the discussion is
not about which monarch is that because
the Queen's no longer there so that's
happened to you the answer is discussed
his whatever I decided it's going to be
that's our history I'm asking you we now
have you made a statement about about
the monarchy and I said to you did you
see no positives from the queen I saw no
positives having the queen as a head of
state right you didn't see any benefit
to the country in terms of the
extraordinary esteem and respect she was
held around the world the fact that she
met more presidents than anybody else I
don't think maybe more prime minister
actually it makes a huge difference it
makes no difference why don't you ask
the presidents why don't you ask all the
presidents who queued up when she died
if we actually talk about the monarchy
rather than the person
why because the queen is no longer
of your monarchy deriding life the
question was this extraordinary figure
who actually and she would never have
been enormous respect she would never
have been Quinn if her uncle wasn't a
Nazi sympathizer who was thrown out she
would never been queen or she would have
had a very short way but she was
completely random and she's no longer
here random she was the only model we've
had the new one the issue is what
happens next now the monarchy is is
actually
the whole at the top of the story was
what's where did you worry about what
you're reading
it's my show
right and here's my question for you
stop reading that I'm not reading that
somebody else has written that it's not
me
look at me look at me and here's my
point what you're not factoring in in
this General whine about the institution
of the monarchy is the extraordinary
influence and Power in my estimation
that her majesty the queen had and I
think Charles can continue which is a
fiction which is not a fiction
summarize why the monarchy is a bad
thing right it stands against our
Democratic principles the institution
has been accused of all sorts of
questionable Behavior it's highly like
our politicians it doesn't matter I
apologize it doesn't matter it does for
the roles the politicians to be thrown
out we can't throw Charles out to the
next election because there is no
election
and it's also bad for our constitution
it centralizes power in the hands of
government at the expense of Parliament
and people so the whole point of having
a republic and no one no serious
Republican in this country is arguing
for a U.S system we're arguing for a
parliamentary Republic which limits
power of the politicians which has been
going really well Independence doesn't
it and hasn't it what has our
parliamentary system well no because
that's the whole point peers that we
reform it by becoming a republic and
change shifting power from government to
Parliament to people having a written
Constitution and a president like they
have an island in Germany who actually
plays these two Ardent Republicans here
right that's fine we're entitled to
their opinion but the polls are also
entitled their opinion you got poll in
October after the queen died about a
month later
um so keep the monarchy 60 abolish the
monarchy 24 don't know 15
overwhelming support for the monarchy so
these two guys can rant about the
monarchy but the bottom line is going
with October recently it's now 30 55
it's Contracting the there is a growth
in support for abolition and there's a
problem because people like you are
running around screaming get rid of
that's the whole point and so thank you
very much for putting that down to my
efforts because the the points
can you let Paula speak
where do you sit with us
the I think it's it's quite astonishing
actually to say that the monarchy isn't
important to this country and isn't
important to the people of this country
I think that's why peers is so surprised
at what you're saying because
as an immigrant as one adopted
um into this country there is no doubt
in my mind that the queen has paid and
the queen and the monarchy has played an
incredibly important role in society and
one that is reflected I think from
childhood right up to and we can see
that not only from sadly the passing of
the queen where I think 4.6 billion
people around the world
watched
and this is the problems
it may be a fantasy
and so I think it is surprising that you
can sit here and at least at least
acknowledge that the figures you're
putting out uh
I go around the world when we lost in
America I haven't been to the United
States but I'm not you've never been to
the places it doesn't matter because
yet
here's my question if you've never been
to the United States I've lived and
worked there for the last 20 years then
you will have no comprehension of the
extraordinary respect they have for the
queen for King Charles now for the
monarchy and it is an abiding respect
that they have and that's why they all
want to come on the state visits and get
the red carpet treatment and I think
it's actually really important to our
special relationship with the United
States the world's number one superpower
I have the the royal family have been
able to be this bridge constant Bridge
through all the political turmoil Alex
well I'm just going to say that I've
been the last direct experience that the
Americans had of monarchy was George III
yeah which which doesn't go particularly
well it went well for that so you've
seen go well for us you say that the
quinton's an exceptional Monarch I agree
with you I I got an absolutely famously
with the queen I like Prince Charles I
think he's a great guy that's not my
argument I've got no animals King
Charles
Adams whatsoever yeah but that's nice
that's not because I don't
because if you ask people the question
you're setting up in the case of an
independent Scotland a new country would
you set up with a hereditary principle
or would you set it up on them I think
it's a really good argument and I
actually don't agree that the hereditary
principle that has been established by
this monarchy in the last hundred years
or so certainly I can look at you know
from my lifetime and slightly Beyond I
think it's been a power of positivity
for the country
principles of power well I just think
you had this family well they don't have
any executive power
yeah
let's say Andrew had been the Elder son
yeah he had been a good guy but he's not
yeah well we'll kick this but I mean you
know it's the so it's a lot would he
have been any worse as a kingdom Boris
Johnson
yes but the point in other words
yes but Boris Johnson is no longer prime
minister right let's trust is no longer
prime minister the greatest
of the last hundred years I would say
was Queen Elizabeth of any kind that is
not a credible argument because it is
incredible argument she was never the
longest race protected by she was the
most respected in all the polls and
anybody she was not required to do or
say anything of any particular uh
controversy she was never subjected to
an election she was never suggested to
uh
he would be defeated heavily because the
point is in an election he would have to
sit here be challenged by people like
you he would have to stand in a in a
studio and be challenged by other
candidates
of the monarchy went to me it's
indisputable in the last hundred years
which is let's say the modern times of
the monarchy that they have been a Force
for good but they haven't felt good what
good have they done what they have done
they've propped up a rotten Constitution
they have been a secretive Institute the
single biggest events in the world
outside of massive news tragedies and
disasters and Terror attacks have been
the big Royal events look at the last
year alone the death of the queen and
her funeral so that's a really positive
thing no no no what's positive is the
way that we then acknowledge these Great
Moments in the royal family and we
recognize how influential in the world
13 only 14 of the country wanted to
celebrate the Jubilee uh last year in
2011 79 of the population I said they
were not interested on true statistics
polling 14 wanted to celebrate it you
give polling in 2011 79 were not
interested 2018 60
a rather successful example of a
presidential system and that's the
Republic of Ireland they've had a
cracking series of Presidents by any
estimation you know Mary Robertson many
Michaelis uh president Higgins I mean
I've been first class president in the
presidential system so but well because
your argument seems to rest on the Her
Majesty the queen was an exceptional
woman I
agreement
the truth is if you were still there if
you end up leader as we've just seen
with you with the queen you'd have been
brown nosing away with the new king for
your heart's control
was the death of the queen I think it
would have been ridiculous yeah
do I think that he's the very best that
we have to have to offer we will find
out what is it that you want do you want
a referendum do you want a brexit style
split this Society doesn't need that the
monarchy is loved in this country
of the kind that we have with Liz trucks
we can't outlive the lettuce
lasts 70 years as a lovely
country who's a calming influence
respected around the world or this trust
you couldn't actually survive Charles
who refused who refuses to pay income
tax refuses to pay inheritance tax
demand secrecy was accused by me to the
police
to contribute around 2.5 which is
million pounds which is not you think
not true to every stat you don't like a
load of baloney stats which aren't he is
you literally just dismiss completely
delusional aren't you you dismissed Yugo
stats you're quoting a report that has
no sources whatsoever there is no
evidence whatsoever that's good
financially for this country and it is a
massive drain on our resources but
that's not the reason but they put MPS
expenses into into the shade with their
business I respect your opinion but
you're completely wrong uh Alex good to
see thank you very much Cindy Paula I
think you're staying with us aren't you
yeah you are uh you're not I'm afraid
extra night should we automatically
believe those who make accusations of
sexual assault or rape I'll speak to a
young man whose life was turned inside
out by a false accusation of rape by
complete science assist you have seen
this on the news all day today his
accuser has been jailed just for eight
years which to me is a scandalously
short amount of time for what she did
but that question remains doesn't it
when an accuser makes accusations you
automatically believe them or have there
been enough cases now to show that that
is a very dangerous road to go down
better to listen and investigate and get
to the truth the debate that after the
break
thank you
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
welcome back my next guest has spent the
last two years in a living nightmare
after being falsely accused of rape by a
woman he barely knew Jordan trengrove
was just 18 when he met Elena Williams
on lights out in Cumbria in 2019 what
happened next landed him in prison for
10 weeks left in Brandon a rapist
destroyed his mental health Eleanor
Williams has since been unmasked as an
evil fantasist and a Serial liar and
today she was jailed for eight and a
half years we've always been to Jordan
let's just see what he had to say last
time he's on the show back in January
I took an overdose in front of my own
mum it was that bad I didn't ever put
other people's feelings first if you get
what I mean because
my life was just too messed up
with all this stuff
well that was Jordan then this is Jordan
now Jordan I was thinking of you today
when I heard about the the sentencing
um just wonder what your reaction was
given this scale of the lying and the
fantasy given that so many people like
you were caught up in this web
um do you think it's long enough eight
and a half years
no I don't think it's long enough at all
um I think she should have been given a
lot longer sentence in my eyes because
she's got time served as well so in
reality she's out in 2025 so a sentence
in reality is only two years so I think
she should have got longer when you saw
the the the lengths that she went to you
know buying a how much you've seen on
video buying a hammer to then attack
herself simply so she could frame people
like you for raping her and grooming
here in other cases and so on and
attacking her what did you feel about
that what did you feel watching her just
so calmly going about buying these tools
to create this fantasy
it makes me feel sick I don't know how
anyone would want to do that or want to
hurt herself in any way like that I
couldn't imagine ever hitting myself
with a hammer or anything like that you
you don't want to do anything like that
so it just makes me feel very sick in a
way
the big debate of course is what happens
with cases like this when you have
somebody come forward who's got all
these apparent injuries and makes all
these incendiary claims of assault and
rape and so on
um should the system the legal system
start from a position of believing
accusers or should they start from a
position of listening to the allegations
and then investigating the facts because
in your case you were named on the front
page of a local paper you had rapists
graffitied over your house and had to
move you were the one who felt suicidal
she meanwhile remained completely
anonymous
yeah I do think that they should be
listened to and taken into account and
regarding like newspapers and being in
the newspapers I think that should be
changed because that was one of the main
things as well what went towards
destroying my life I shouldn't have been
named in that paper when I was on the
remanded you know like fair enough if I
was convicted
yeah I mean you know when I think about
the scale of what she did and I heard
the sentence and like you say you know
if she behaves herself in prison she'll
be out in the next two years you know to
me I don't understand why she didn't get
a life sentence frankly
I think the exact same I think she
should have been given life private in
the course of Justice can hold the
maximum of life and she's destroyed so
many lives not only mine so she should
have her life took away from her
Jordan how have you got on with
rebuilding your life now has it helped
having her now be named identified and
jailed for lying and you be associated
with that as people know you know you in
able to go back to your place where you
grew up and people treating you now as
an innocent victim rather than as a
supposed rapist
um I don't like going into Barrel so
much anymore I don't like going anywhere
near that town and said to my partner
after the sentencing I said this gives
us two years to just move out the area
because I don't want to be in the area
when she's released as it is but it's I
can rebuild my life now and I've started
like last time I seen you I've been
doing steps towards rebuilding my life
yes I have
if you had been found guilty
of the allegations that she made against
you
had you been told by a lawyer how long
you may have to have served
I think my solicitor told me back then
it had been looking at like 22 years
because of the severity of it you see
that that to me is just extraordinary
isn't it you were told you might get 22
years in prison for a pack of lies about
you and the person that perpetrated the
lies ends up getting eight and a half
literally about a third
exactly and I think it's so unfair
because if I was sent to prison it had
been so many more years and this is
exactly what I said to quite a lot of
depressed when it came out of car
accident if I was sent to prison I'm
guilty on what she accused me of it had
been a lot longer
but she can go out and Destroy and
fabricate and do so many people's life
or damage and pretty much just get a
slap on the wrist it just shows it's
very I don't know it's not it's messed
up in the system yeah I mean to me it's
grotesquely unfair and imbalanced Jordan
really appreciate you coming back on
tonight must have been a difficult day
for you but ultimately I guess a
satisfying one that she at least uh is
remaining behind bars for another two
years or so but like you say ridiculous
that then you have to fear going back to
where you want you're from because
you're worried that she'll be there
again which she will be in two years it
seems ridiculous
um I really appreciate you coming back
Jordan thank you very much
thank you very much
all right Ava this guy I've interviewed
him a couple of times now he's so like
impressively calm eloquent but there's a
kind of searing anger there too about
what he's had to endure 18 years old
I've got three sons in my 20s this is
every parent's nightmare for a son now
I'm very aware that a lot of women that
make allegations of sexual sort of rape
get no justice the the rates of of
conviction for these things are
ridiculously low I totally agree with
that but for the purposes of this debate
it's specifically about what's happened
to him
to me it seems ludicrous to carry on
with this notion that all accusers
should be believed we saw it with the
nasty Nick character who invented all
the stories the pedophile stories about
you know some of the most eminent people
in the country we've seen it now with
this woman so we've seen it from a man
and woman to me there should never be a
presumption of belief why should there
be I think that gosh I don't really know
where to begin with I mean we live in a
country where under one percent of you
know rapes even go to conviction so I'm
quite taken aback by what you said why
should you automatically believe an
allegation because we live in a country
where women aren't believed and it is
extremely difficult for women to come
forward and talk about sexual assault
that has happened to them and look this
situation is grotesque you were right to
call it that it's abhorrent and he's a
very nice guy but it's quite clear that
the girl in question is really unwell if
you look at her mental health all around
this case she was reported missing one
year 32 times in what in just one year
by her own mother she's clearly not well
I actually don't even think she should
be going to prison I think she's moving
I think she should be sectioned I think
she's not well and I actually don't
think prison is a safe environment for
her but I don't really care if it's a
safe environment for her frankly and I
don't think that being on well as a
justification you wouldn't be saying
justification this might be an
explanation if we had a male if this guy
had been convicted of what he'd been
charged or accused of doing and arrested
over like you said 22 years you'd have
called him a monster he wouldn't have
made some excuse about his mental health
yeah I mean why are you making excuse
for her I'm not giving her an excuse you
are I said you shouldn't even be
impressed I'm explaining I think I don't
think that she is well and I don't think
she's going to be rehabilitated in a
prison I actually think it's going to be
really awful for her and actually as an
indictment of our justice system she
wasn't indictment is that he would have
gone down for 22 years she's going to be
out in the next two years having served
half of the night and a half years this
is going to be any better she's not
going to be any better for it prisoners
about Rehabilitation she is you wouldn't
be saying that if he had been found
guilty and gone to prison for rape
no I think that's a false equivalent
it's not a false equivalence he's
literally just told you he was told if
these lies stuck and he and he was found
guilty 22 years in prison you would have
been quite happy with that right if if
she got through the Justice if he was
convicted and the justice system had
convicted him yes
I've been quite happy here's the Dilemma
for me
I do think it's completely wrong that so
few rape allegations end up with
convictions when in many cases we know
they're probably true so this is a
absolute disgrace in this country about
what happens to women who make
legitimate claims and the system lets
them down I think we can all agree on
that right but this is a different area
this is the area of what the police do
when somebody comes and says XYZ and I
feel strongly now after several very
high profile cases you cannot make a
presumption of belief you cannot call
them victims from the start because they
may not be they might be fantasies but
surely appears there's a difference
between belief and listening to someone
yes seriously investigating it by people
who are really so that's what I said
qualify that's my business and I think
David thinks that's outrageous look
you've got genuinely looked at me in
total discussion yeah she was but but I
think that's because you didn't consider
the point about seriously listening
properly investigating by real
Specialists who understand the
likelihood I know a guy who uh he um
luckily he did remain anonymous but he
had 18 months of absolute hell on Earth
right uh and it turned it went all the
way through trial and at the end of the
trial during 10 minutes uh and he was in
this case in this case this poor kid is
not even 20. and his name is branded in
all his local town as a rapist of a
local paper front page she meanwhile
remains completely Anonymous yes now I
know the argument for the police is if
you name people who are accused of
sexual assault rape it encourages other
people to come forward exactly but
actually why should he be named and
shamed in that circumstance and a woman
like that remain anonymous until she's
finally charged with lying so this is
about what happens in our minds if you
work in family law I do but this is
about what happens in my mind he's not
named and shamed but he was he's named
and it's the approach that's taken by
people because we have to all remember
that you are innocent until proven
guilty and unfortunately we forget that
in society and Christopher Jeffries is a
classic example he was the unfortunate
landlord
um who went on to later sue the press
and certain individuals who behave
recklessly and I was one of them at the
time no no defense for that absolutely
lutely and so this is about our
responsibility as a society knowing what
we know and we saw it with that poor
missing woman recently who disappeared
exactly everyone racing to conclusions
about that exactly
the woeful police handling I can
possibly answer but the point is we all
have to take responsibility in a society
where human beings are running a system
should we believe accusers from the
start absolutely it's not about why
believing accuses it is because if you
if you believe them you call them if you
call them has failed you called them
that guy that guy Nick who yeah who
invented all the stories right yeah he
was believed and in fact the the
commander of the Met police at the time
called him a victim right at the moment
a policeman of that rank calls somebody
a victim there is a presumption of guilt
and a presumption that everything he's
saying is true yes and it turned out it
was all complete fantasy and I think you
can avoid all this if you say look
someone comes with navigation and you
say right we're taking this seriously we
absolutely will treat you with due
respect we'll take all the details
downward properly investigate then it's
then it's compellingly important that
the police investigate it properly but
only at the point that you have enough
to charge somebody in my belief should
anyone even be considered to be named
and shamed right and that is technically
what should happen that's not what
happens but exactly and why not because
people talk the police will inform them
why is what I'm saying wrong because you
you can name two people two men that
this has happened to can you name all of
the thousands of women who can't get a
conviction why is it going to be either
or you're making it an either one
actually you are you are
but I'm so I'm not I'm saying there
should be a presumption of an
allegations being made not a presumption
of a true allegation do you know what a
woman has to go through do you know what
a woman has to do to record a rape would
you want if you had a daughter would you
want her having to give her knickers
over there would you like her to give
her underwear over here but I think you
are completing two different things I'm
not convicting what's that got to do
with the presumption of innocence or
guilt no because right now we are
talking about could you believe it is
and has ruined someone's life and it is
grotesque comparing that to women who
are assaulted and should be believed why
would she believed so that they can go
through the process
and why was he disbelieved because she
was a woman reporting a sexual assault
she also did turn up because she would
have hammered to her face and she did
look like she had been assaulted right
the police did let him down I will say
that the police in this situation why is
it sensible to just believe accusers I
don't even think we can have that
conversation because actually victims
are never believed it's very rare that
they are this is just a high profile
case where a woman
unfortunately has been believed wrongly
Richard
we've just got to have higher quality
Specialists who've got more experience
about assessing these and quickly so
where's the money for that Richard we've
got to find it we've got to find it that
is not a good enough answer we have to
get the reality well then we'll adapt to
the police this is what happens I'm not
talking about defunding the police
you've got to increase it you've got to
increase the quality it's not good
enough you know what it's complicated
but I do think there have been too many
of these cases now and the problem
starts if you just say I believe you
from the start rather than I listen to
you
which is what happens in every other
form of crime right pretty much
right why do we just assume people are
telling the truth
why listen and investigate properly of
course treat with respect absolutely
listen to them seriously then
investigate otherwise you get into this
kind of situation which I think is
incredibly unfair the problem is when
the system is so backed up against those
let's all agree the system the system is
deeply flawed and it has to be and the
conviction rates are a disgrace it's
interesting debate but thank you for
having it coming next tonight prime
minister wish you soon that pledges to
review sex education in schools I'm in a
growing round about graphic lessons for
kids how young is too young to learn
about sex
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
Rishi sunax ordered urgent review into
sex education classes after claims of
extreme teaching is laid out by
conservative MP Miriam Cates in
Parliament last week
graphic lessons on oral sex how to choke
your partner safely and 72 genders this
is what passes for relationships and sex
education in British schools across the
country children are being subjected to
lessons that are age inappropriate
extreme sexualizing and inaccurate this
is not a victory for equality it is a
catastrophe for childhood
what join me now is columnist and author
of stolen youth Carol Markowitz welcome
to Carol um this has been a big issue
obviously over in the states it's a big
issue now in the UK as well and it just
raises this whole question of how how
young is too young to even get into
discussions at school about sex and
gender and so on
well I think that that's a great
question and one we should answer before
the materials get to the schools a lot
of the materials that are being featured
right now both in the US and in the UK I
think are far too graphic for elementary
and middle school which in the U.S is um
until about 14 15. so I think that when
we look at this kind of materials and
that they end up in our schools I think
we need to trace back how that happened
and really get to the bottom of it
because this isn't accidental this isn't
just accidentally Landing in our schools
somebody's pushing this and we need to
find out why what I mean that's a big
question I don't I don't get it really
I've got four kids and I'd be horrified
at some of this stuff which I'm reading
now had been put on them and they were
young and impressionable kids at school
I don't understand why it started it
never used to be that this was going on
in schools
right I think the sexualization of
children is happening younger and
younger and
our books stolen youth we really point
out that this is part of a a overarching
indoctrination campaign to throw kids
into kind of a disarray they're much
easier to convince into things and you
know in the US we call it the the word
has been grooming but there is some
element of grooming to this when kids
are introduced to sexual Concepts too
early they're literally groomed to be
taken advantage of and again I think
that you know before we all dismiss this
as oh wow this is so weird how did this
happen in our schools like this must be
an accident we need to investigate how
this is happening and and why and and
really trace it back to where these
books are coming from I live in Florida
where this has become a giant debate my
Governor Ron DeSantis has demanded that
these books be pulled out of school
libraries and for this he's been called
you know a book burner a book Banner but
nobody wants porn in the school library
I haven't met a parent yet who's for it
so I think he's really doing what
parents want I completely agree with
DeSantis I don't understand why he's
being portrayed as the devil here the
people who obey living in a devilish
manner to me are the ones putting all
this stuff in the schools to start with
yeah I agree obviously and living in
Florida just means that one fewer thing
for me to worry about with the kids and
knowing that my governor and the parents
around me are supportive of the fact
that you know pulling these books out is
not book Banning it's not book burning
it's none of that it's really just
taking into account what kids are
designed for and what they're not and
pushing these ideas on two young
children we know it's going to have a
backlash we know that there's going to
be some some bad effects on them and I
don't know why we continue to pretend
that this is some you know non-important
issue they don't people don't run for
school board for example on let's get
born into the school libraries it's all
done in secret but once you discover it
I think it's up to the parents and the
schools to act and I like that my
Governor Ron DeSantis is doing that yeah
I mean long story involved a child who
allegedly was made to leave the
classroom when he disagreed with a drag
queen that there were 72 genders I mean
the world's gone completely nuts it's
the child who queried this who got told
he had to leave not the drag queen
spewing some nonsense about 72 genders
yeah I like to imagine that my kids
would say no there's not 72 genders in
their class and not not to have a
problem leaving the classroom when they
were challenged on that but that's
really also the thing parents need to
lay the foundation at home throughout
the book stolen youth we teach parents
how to do that because your kids are
going out into the world they are being
introduced to new ideas and New Concepts
and if you want to challenge those
Concepts before the kid gets
indoctrinated you have to teach them at
home you have to lay your values out for
them at home and you need to give them
the strength to move through the world
and be brave yeah I totally agree uh
Carol thank you very much David joining
me I appreciate it thank you Paris well
Kevin next question Thomas fan and Bruce
quits as Ambassador for Refuge pushed
out really after claiming she
trivialized domestic abuse as part of a
discussion about Stanley Johnson Boris
Johnson's father wasn't she just doing
her job
debating that next
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel note
what are you uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speech writers here but we do and
I promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
and coming up on The Talk Gary lineker
lashes out at Elon Musk over Twitter
trolls and there are calls to crack down
on Tick Tock over spying and security
concerns but if you're worried about
what's left to scroll through online
don't fear Meghan markle's tip to bring
back her blog we're discussing all of
that at nine
is there anything on God's Earth that
people want less than Meghan Markle
Reviving a Blog TIG absolutely not
um just want to do a shout out to Mick
Jagger who it turned out was at the
Arsenal Fulham game at the weekend with
a baseball cup and I wasn't quite sure
what it had on it but it turned out he
had uh the letters dilf which uh we've
got one here uh and I don't think I can
actually say what that stands for other
than if you know you know right
[Laughter]
um
I want to talk about Fiona Bruce because
I got quite angry about this because I
was watching questions the other night
and this exchange happened let's watch
The Exchange first
for a change I'm not
I'm not blaming Boris Johnson or Stanley
Johnson actually can he was a wife
beater Stanley Johnson on record
um okay let me just let me just
interview I'm not I'm not disputing what
we're saying but just so everyone knows
what this is referring to so Sally
Johnson's uh wife spoke to a journalist
on bar and she said that Stanley Johnson
had broken her nose and she'd end up in
hospital as a result Stanley Johnson has
not commented publicly on that friends
of his have said it did happen it was a
one-off yes but it did happen
now as a result of that uh Fiona Bruce
who worked with Refuge a domestic abuse
charity for 25 years and been one of
their top ambassadors has been forced to
step down a refuge just threw her to The
Virtue signaling wolves with a
ridiculous statement in my opinion
saying this was completely unacceptable
we know the words weren't fionas they
said but the words were she was legally
obliged to read out this doesn't lessen
their impact or we can't lose sight of
that these words minimize the
seriousness of domestic abuse this has
been re-traumatizing for survivors what
a load of nonsense sorry what a load of
nonsense Fiona Bruce is a decent person
who read out a prepared BBC legal
statement if somebody had raised a
Stanley Johnson thing and for that she's
been thrown out all that work she did
has been thrown out he gonna defend this
over well and I think actually it's the
BBC who seemed to be in the wrong here
because they it looks like they've left
her out to dry a little bit I mean it
seems like there might have been an open
BBC to do that to one of their
presenters I mean it's maybe there was
an overzealous producer who was in her
ear and you know was telling her to
correct it but actually what Jasmin was
saying didn't need correcting right he
hasn't been responding Richard my point
is this idea that Refuge felt the need
to say it's been re-traumatizing for
survivors it's just nonsense and it's so
ungrateful of them a is nonsense but you
know if the owners work so hard for them
and what it will do it will
disincentivize other celebrities to help
really important Charities like that if
you know the first sign of the slightest
slip of the tongue you're going to be
dish the BBC though I mean you know they
they have completely not supported
terrible
shameful a bit like The Limited Fiasco
that's a different story am I wrong you
are completely wrong you are wrong
because and I I hate to say it but Fiona
Bruce does have to take some
responsibility for this you've been an
ambassador for refuge for over 20 years
you would understand the impact the
severity of those words it only happened
once his friend said there is no eat
where's the legal obligation statement
that's been made where's the legal log
base all that needed to be said was
allegedly that's all that needed to be
said now as an ambassador of Refuge if I
saw that statement and was being asked
to read out that statement I would have
said guys I'm a little bit uncomfortable
what about this have you ever done
presenting live television with an
audience I haven't with an audience but
it is my job to speak carefully
told you've got to read the the
clarification on Stanley Johnson she
read it all right it could have been
worded slightly better than it turned
out then why is it
it's really hard it's really high
pressure on something like question time
and you can't do it word by word she was
told what to say and then she was thrown
to the Wolves by the BBC and by the
charity I heard that that is response
I.E I didn't want to say it or I raised
a challenge with it and speculate there
because honestly I think he's cowardly
by refuge and douglasism to do this it's
pathetic by the BBC and they should all
be better than this Fiona Bruce is one
of the most decent people you meet after
all she did that's how they treat her I
just want a tip of the time I just
wonder if you would have that attitude
in terms of dismissing
dismissing the trauma and the
suggestions
oh my god I've just been traumatized by
what you just said yeah yes it's the
short answer that question and secondly
do you know everything that we've had to
listen to today in terms of it only
happened once that's like 1980s
something else before we have time we
discuss this a lot today which is
left-wing people you too I might have
the problem apparently you do suffer
from genuine more anxiety than everybody
else it's the politics of depression
that apparently one's that are liberal
young people in America they're
suffering surging rates of depressive
symptoms compared to conservatives it is
depressing being on your side of this
fence well I don't think that's quite it
is I think that if you are you know get
veering more towards left in politics
particularly in the universe
Running Out of Time quick there we are
you just said from me thank you Pat what
are you up to keep it on sex and stay
happy and you've got one life
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel don't
worry every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one two
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night